ونحيكم من جديد هناك اتفاق السلام من نوع
ما في الشرق الاوسط ليس بين اسرائيل
والعرب بل بين السعوديه وايران الخصمين
منذ عقود ولم تتوسط فيه الولايات المتحده
بل لعبت الصين الدوره البارزه في هذا ما
نشرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز بشان الاتفاق
السعودي الايرانيه الذي تم توقيعه في
بكينه الجمعه الماضيه حيث قالت ميرك تايمز
ان ما حدث يعتبر بعيدا عن مخيله الكثيرين
وهو التحول الذي قلب الطاوله على عواصم
العالم فقد انقلبت التحالفات والمنافسات
التي حكمت الدبلوماسيه لاجيال في الوقت
الراهن على الاقل والكلام مثلا للصحيفه
ووصفت صحيفه الاتفاق بالتغير الكبير الذي
حدث بلحظه ووفق قولها فان الامريكيين
الذين كانوا اللاعبين المركزين في الشرق
الاوسط على مدى ثلاثه ارباع القرن الماضي
يجدون انفسهم الان على الهامش وترى
الصحيفه ان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان يلتفت الى الصين حاليا فيما قال
ستيفن ايكوك في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه
قال ان البعض في الخليج بات يرى بوضوح ان
هذا هو القرن الصيني لقد اعرب السعوديون
عن اهتمامهم بالانضمام الى منظمه شنغهاي
لتعاون وفق قوله
اعود من جديد الى ضيوفي سيد تشاو قبل
البدء بمناقشه ما تضمنه هذا المقال وما
تضمنته كذلك بعض القراءات الامريكيه
البعض يطرح سؤال ان كان العصر القادم هو
عصر الصين ان كانت الصين قادره على ان
تكون على راس هرم النظام العالمي فدخل
الصيني ما الذي يقال في هذا الاطار
برايي على رقم عن تاسيس تاثير الولايات
المتحده في العالم لا سيما في الشرق
الاوسط لا يزال كبير كبيرا جدا والى عند
نفوذ الصين يتوسع بالصوره ايضا ويخطف
اختيار المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لمصافحه ايران في بكين عاد الى الى سعر
اشاره الى واشنطن مفادها عن دول شرق
الاوسط لا يزال بامكانها تحقيق واشياء
عظيمه بدون واشنطن
واعتقد ان مغارنه مع مع الولايات المتحده
الى سياسات خارجيه الصين يمكن ان تستمر
لفتره اطول مثلا يختلف
اداره ترامب تجاهها البرداني في جامعها
العالم اختلافا كبيرا عن موقف اداره
ومع ذلك زارت السياسه الخارجيه ريسين دون
تغيير
عدم تداخل في شؤون داخليه والبحث عن فرصه
لتعاون وتعزيز تنميه السلميه في العالم
وهذا يسخر على الصين كسب كسب لدول لدول
اخرى ومن خلال
اتفاق بين بين ايران والسعوديه وقدمت
الصين اعتقد قدمت الصين طريقه جديده
لتعزيز السلام في في الكثير من القضيه
ساخنه مثلا قضيه فلسطينيه اسرائيل
اسرائيليه
والحرب يمن وحتى عربي روسيه اوكرانيه
فاعتقد ان سيكون هناك على مزيد ومزيد من
الدول تسيب بحساس الصين بالمسؤوليات دكتور
عبد العزيز هل ترى حضرتك بان هذا القرن
سيكون بعنو ان القرن الصيني تعلم حضرتك
بانه سابقا القرن العشرين كان يسمى القرن
الامريكي القرن الثامن وتسع عشر القرون
البريطانيه هل القرن 21 يمكن ان يكون قرنا
صينيا ليس فقط بالاعتماد على هذه الخطوه
ولكن ان تكون هذه الخطوه مقدمه لان تزرع
الصين حضورها وقوتها في مختلف المجالات في
العالم
يعني بالتاكيد الصين تتوسع ويعني مشروعها
الكبير الطريق او طريق الحرير يسمى له
اهميه كبيره لانه يعتمد على التوسع
الاقتصادي واي توسع اقتصادي في العالم
لابد ان يتبعه توسع سياسي وامني ايضا عشان
حمايه المصالح الصينيه طبعا خليني اديك
مثال الولايات المتحده كان في اجتماع حول
افريقيا والولايات المتحده اعتمدت 50
مليون دولار حتى يكون هنالك توسع في
العلاقه الامريكيه الافريقيه في الوقت
اللي الصين اصلا اليوم علاقتها حوالي 350
مليار دولار فالصين توسعت متواجده في
مناطق اخرى كثيره وتنافس فيها الولايات
المتحده هي الاقتصاد الثاني الان طبعا ما
زال امامها بعض تحديات هل تقبل كثير من
الدول ان تبيع سلع رئيسيه بالايوان بدلا
من الدولار هل سوف يحقق نتائج مثلا
تتوقعها الصين والدول اللي معاها بالت تمر
بسهوله ولكن هي تسير في خطوات يعني
تنافسيه كبيره تحقق من خلالها نتائج كبيره
ولكن ايضا التحديات اماما سهله ضيفك طبعا
تفضلوا ذكر بوضوح ان الصين لا تريد ان
تدخل في منافسه عسكريه او هيمنه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا ايضا
يعني يطرح تساؤل القدرات العسكريه
الامريكيه فيما يسمى
بالبلو وتركبيليتي المياه الزرقاء العميقه
بمعنى حاملات الطائرات قدرته على الوصول
قدرات الستلات اللي عندها يعني مختلف
الامكانيات والقدرات العسكريه ما زالت
تتفوق على كثير من منافسينها الى مرحله
معينه ولكن ايضا هنالك خلل في الاقتصاد
الامريكي وهذا ما شاهدناه في اليومين
الماضيه افلاس بعض البنوك الكبيره اللي
كانت موجوده في الولايات المتحده هذا
الافلاس الاقتصادي وهذه الاشكاليات ربما
تؤثر وربما تطرح تساؤلات كثيره لدول كثيره
اعتمدت على سرعه اساسيه في التسعير سلاحها
وبضائعها لكن
بالتاكيد الخطوات مستمره الصين تسير فيها
نفوذها في الدول جنوب شرق اسيا في افريقيا
في امريكا اللاتينيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بالتحديد الدول العربيه انا ذكرت
350 مليون دولار دول الخليج الوحده 130
مليون دولار من هذا الجانب فلذلك هذا
التوسع اللي عنده لن اعتمدت على توسيع
صناعاتها والدخول في اشياء كثيره بالتاكيد
سوف تواجه تحدياته سوف تواجه كثير من
التعطيل وسوف تواجه مثل ما روسيا واجهت
اليوم تكتل كبير يعني موقفنا في روسيا
نريد ان نحافظ على توازننا بمعنى انه لا
نقطع العلاقه مع روسيا ولا ننظم الى
المعسكر الذي يعادي روسيا في نفس الوقت
احنا قدمنا المساعدات لاوكرانيا وقبلنا
يعني ولم نقبل بالاحتلال الروسي
صحيح احضرني فقط على المقاطعه الوقت ضيق
الوقت يبدو بان الاعلام الامريكي لم يكن
بهذه الدرجه من الحياد يعني اليوم سيد
طوني الاعلام الامريكي وكانه هناك استياء
من هذه الاتفاقيه من وساطه الصين هناك حتى
حديث مبالغ فيه يقول البعض عن تغير بوصله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه باتجاه الصين ما
تفسير ذلك
في الاعلام الاعلام المجمل الاعلام مش كل
الاعلام طبعا يا نقاط الكلام الحزب
الديمقراطي وهاي يعني هناك مشكله بين
الحزب الديمقراطي والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
تعود الى مساله
تم بسرعه هي مساله التسليح في انواع اسلحه
وتسهيل
الانواع الاسلحه كانت طالبت فيها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والحزب الديمقراطي
تحديدا
اعذرني انتهى تماما الواقع تعظني على
المقاطعه طوني بدران شكرا لك دكتور عبد
العزيز بن صقر تشاو تشين شكرا جزيلا لكم
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]